the economy is in a confusing place
right now and there's a lot of
speculation around this one word the
latest sign that we may be headed for a
recession are we actually in a recession
I do not think the U.S is currently in a
recession so what actually determines
when the U.S enters a recession it's not
this or this or this no one chart
determines a recession rather it's these
eight people a group known as the
business cycle dating committee here's
how this group decides when the US is in
a recession and why knowing that date is
so important
foreign
if you're going to lose your job it
matters if your income is going down it
matters to business if they're going to
be selling fewer cars or fewer
televisions so our entire economy is
oriented towards producing more and a
recession is when everything goes wrong
and we go in the other direction knowing
when a recession starts and ends is
important because it can inform how we
respond to these downturns later this
group of economists is selected by the
nber or National Bureau of economic
research each member on the committee is
an expert in well business cycle dating
business Cycles are patterns of Peaks or
high points and troughs low points in
economic activity that period between a
peak and a trough is a recession the
nber has been dating business Cycles
back to at least the 1920s but
formalized the committee in 1978. the
committee is non-partisan and its makeup
doesn't follow set guidelines the number
of people on it can vary and some have
been there since its Inception it's
included people like former fed chairman
Ben Bernanke thank you what they try to
do is seek balance and really uh even
handed data only approach to just
looking at the data and what they show
and put the politics out of it the
committee doesn't meet regularly only
when economic data looks like it might
be reaching a peak or trough so what are
the data they're actually looking at the
nber officially defines a recession as a
decline in economic activity that's
spread across the economy and lasts more
than a few months to track that economic
activity the committee looks at several
indicators income employment real sales
personal consumption expenditures or the
value of stuff bought by people in the
U.S and industrial production what they
try to do is they try to look at Broad
indicators that that measure all of the
economy at once across these categories
they're looking for three things depth
which is how far indicators are
declining diffusion which is how far the
decline has spread across the economy
and duration which is how long those
declines last if each shows deep
declines lasting a long time that would
Mark a clear start to a recession just
take a look at 2007 when all of these
categories saw a significant drop after
December but it's not always so
clear-cut the economy is this Dynamic
organism and it doesn't always behave
according to the textbooks or the
conventions about how we think it should
be hate the time that each indicator
Peaks can vary widely this chart shows
how many months before or after a
recession start date that some of these
reached a peak for example in 1980 sales
started to decline 10 months ahead of
the committee's economic Peak or look at
2020 when the committee called a
recession at the start of the covid-19
pandemic even though the downturn had
only lasted two months James viterba the
president of the nper explained the
reasoning on CNBC when the start of the
recession was initially declared the
depth of this downturn is such that the
committee felt comfortable labeling that
as a as a recession yeah the thing with
these economists is they want to be
scientific but there's some art to this
too there's some kind of just like
feeling around a problem and just saying
we got to make our best call this method
of calling a recession isn't standard
many analysts and commentators across
the globe look at GDP or gross domestic
product for guidance on when a recession
has started GDP is a measure of how much
goods and services a nation produces the
common rule of thumb is that anytime it
declines in two consecutive quarters
that indicates a recession you can see
that was the case in 1990 but again this
data alone isn't enough because the
challenge with that is that how much
stuff we produce as an economy doesn't
tell the whole story it only tells part
of the story if you look at 2022 GDP did
drop in these two quarters but
employment a key indicator for the
committee was still strong so the nber
didn't call it a recession at least it
hasn't yet that's because the committee
usually doesn't call a recession for
months down the line just look at the
start of the 2008 recession which the
committee didn't make an official
announcement about for a year
the fact of the matter is a lot of these
data that are that they're looking at
are revised uh months or years down the
road and so when they make these
declarations they want to be on firm
ground they don't want to be revising
the dates that they put out there as
often as the data are revised so they
tend to act with a little bit of a lag
so when the committee does make a call
it doesn't often have that much effect
on the current economic situation still
knowing the precise time a recession has
started is important politically when
someone is running for president or
re-election people make judgments about
whether that person has done a good job
uh in office and so we look at whether
there was a recession and it's also
important economically by having that
sharpened view they could kind of do
some analysis of what were interest
rates doing around then what was
inflation doing what what were jobs
doing so by sharpening your view of the
past the hope is you can make better
judgments about the present though the
committee hasn't yet determined if the
US has entered a recession economists in
a wsj survey think we're likely headed
into one this year during and after the
kovid shock there's just been a lot of
turbulence in this economy and so we
have indicators going up and down in
different Divergent directions that make
it very hard to read how the economy is
behaving right now and since the
committee is backward looking there
isn't a clear timeline on when or if an
announcement could come
[Music]
foreign